في اسرائيل تصاعد الوضع السياسي والامني
على خلفيه ازمه التعديلات القضائيه وسط
استنفار الامني وتاهب للشرطه والجيش فيما
تتسع الاضرابات لتشمل قطاع الصحه والطيران
بعد اضراب شامل للجامعات حيث اعلنت قبل
قليل الهيئه المطارات الاسرائيليه وقف
اقلاع الطائرات بمطار بنغوريون واما
التصعيد والفوضى اعلن قد ذو الاحتجاج
تمسكهم بالغاء التعديلات القضائيه وليس
مجرد تعليقها حيث اتجه رئيس الوزراء في
الساعه الاخيره لبحث التعليق التعديلات
وفي خضم ما تشهده اسرائيل من احداث
وتطورات متسارعه
الاغلبيه بين وزراء بين وزراء حزب العكود
الاسرائيلي ايضا تؤيد وقف التعديلات
القضائيه بحسب مراسل العربيه وفي الاثناء
مشاهدينا اعلنت قناه 12 الاسرائيليه ان
لجنه الدستور بالكنيسه الاسرائيلي صادقت
على التعديلات القضائيه بالقراءتين
الثانيه الثالثه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هجم زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل الا به
حكومه نتنياهو مؤكدا في مؤتمر من داخل
الكنيست على انها فقدت بوصلتها واصبحت
خطرا على اسرائيل وامنها واضاف ان حكومه
نتنياهو طردت وزير الدفاع وافكارت لانه
قال الحقيقه ودع قيادات حزب الايكود الى
الوقوف في وجه ما وصفه بجنون الحكومه